during last night's came people talking  about this msg the next television  network showed a graphic that Jeremy Lin  with Jeremy Lin in it that some people  think may be a little bit racist here's  the graphic that MSG put up it's Jeremy  Lin yes  that's real Jeremy Lin coming out of a  fortune cookie and they put that up on  MSG and of course some people are very  upset now and other people don't see  what the problem is at all unfortunately  here's the real problem I watched the  entire game and MSG showed other Jeremy  Lin graphics that I thought were even  more offensive than that one I don't  know why people weren't talking about  these ones for example there was this  one that said check it out he does the  math - and then there was this one that  said taking opponents to the cleaners  then finally this one that said he's  he's only good at driving to the food  [Applause]  that is wrong that is wrong it's my  mayor Quimby